- [Voiceover] The perimeter of the figure
is 24 centimeters.
What is the length of the missing side?
So we're told this figure down here
has a perimeter of 24 centimeters.
The perimeter is 24 centimeters.
So what that tells us is that the distance
around the entire outside
is 24 centimeters.
But what we want to know
is what is the length
of the missing side?
Well, the missing side
is going to be the side
we're not told, so it
will be this one here.
Because we have this question mark.
It's missing, it is not labeled.
So we've got to figure out
what number should go on this missing side
so that the entire
length is 24 centimeters.
So let's start with what we do know.
We know that this top length,
this top side, has a
length of six centimeters,
plus, going down the left,
has a length of five more centimeters.
Plus across the bottom
is four more centimeters.
And the last known side is
another four centimeters.
So when we add those
plus this mystery side,
we should get a perimeter of 24.
The entire distance, all of this,
the six, plus the five, plus
the four, plus the four,
plus this mystery number should get us
to a perimeter of 24.
So let's add over here and try
to make it a little simpler
to find our missing side.
I can add in any order,
and I love making tens,
so I'm gonna say six and four is 10.
10 plus five is 15.
And 15 plus four more is 19.
So we know where 19 centimeters
come from on this shape.
Here's the 19 centimeters
are here outlined in blue.
So how many more centimeters,
what length must this missing side be
to get us a total distance
around the outside of 24 centimeters.
We can do that math,
19 plus one more is 20.
And then plus four more
to 24, so one more to 20,
and four more, that's
a total of five more.
So the missing side length
is five centimeters.
This side right here
must be five centimeters
in order for the total perimeter to be 24.
Okay, let's look at one more.
This time it says that the
perimeter of a rectangle
is 32 meters.
And one side is 11 meters.
What is the length of the missing side?
So again, we have a missing side.
So let's visualize this.
Let's draw ourselves a rectangle here.
This is what a rectangle looks like.
And we know that one
side is 11 centimeters,
so one side is 11, or meters, excuse me.
And because we know that
this side is 11 meters,
we also know that this side is 11 meters,
on a rectangle, opposite sides are equal.
So those two we know.
But what we don't know are
this top and the bottom.
Those are the missing sides.
So what are those side lengths?
Well, again, we know we have
a perimeter of 32 meters,
we're told right here
perimeter is 32 meters.
So, the question is 11 plus 11
for these two sides, 11 and 11.
Plus some mystery number
and then plus that same mystery number
because these two sides are equal.
And that has to give us
a total of equals 32.
Because 32 is the total
distance around the outside.
So let's add the 11s.
11 plus 11 is 22.
So 22 plus how many more gets us to 32?
Well, 22 plus 10 more is 32,
but if we label one of these sides as 10,
then the other one would have to be zero.
So they have to be equal,
so how can we equally split
those 10 meters between the two sides?
Half of 10 is five.
So these sides are each five meters.
22, five plus five is ten.
22 plus 10 is 32.
So the missing side length is five meters.